if you can manage to stay within its
constantly shifting rules
you can pretty much do whatever the hell
you want on
twitch it's what makes the platform so
cool
and for streamer clint 1717
doing whatever the hell you want means
streaming from your bathtub
getting pokeman's name tattooed on your
back
and allegedly rigging your own talk show
guys we are getting closer and closer
every day to 2 million subscribers so if
you haven't yet
scroll down and subscribe to the channel
you'll help us get there even
faster and while you're at it hit that
notification bell
so you never miss new content ever again
so on top of being a just chatting
streamer clint 1717
or just clint was once a producer for
many of the talk shows that popular
streamer austin
runs on his channel the number one spot
for talk shows on twitch
he basically booked guests and generally
made sure that all of the chaos of
running a 15 person twitch show
was organized but when it comes to his
personal stream well
it's chaos i'm an animal i'm unmatched
there's not another [ __ ] on
there i'm gonna beat you next week that
can literally do
anything like this uh endurance wise i'm
the ultimate e athlete
uh i am an apex predator that's clint
after spending 125 [ __ ] hours in his
bathtub where he primarily streams
here's clint on why a bathtub i've
always had this idea in the back of my
head that if everything else just fell
through that there's maybe a chance i
could go start like a cult somewhere
like maybe out in the woods or something
and so throughout that stream you know i
had predicated that god had told me
to go live in the bathtub and that that
was some sort of spiritual voyage
uh that was all actual [ __ ] i never
actually talked to god at least as far
as i know
and it was just it was just like an
aesthetic that i thought was funny
there's sort of like a set aesthetic for
twitch where you're sitting in front of
a computer
there's so many interesting ways that
you can kind of film yourself that are
really
dumb but they work for whatever reason
and that just happened to be one of
those ways that
just clicked with people i guess a lot
of his content is typical to what you'd
find in the just chatting section on
twitch
on top of hanging out with his chat he
hosts a lot of random
challenges with the winner either
getting hosted or given
some money and these aren't complicated
either last year clint hosted a standing
challenge
a contest to see who could stand the
longest all while playing it up for the
camera and talking
[ __ ] to the other contestants she looks
like uh
the shia labeouf music video is a shine
of the finish
so far while working on this show i've
covered a
human v tuber hybrid a streamer who
scams scammers
and a dude who got popular off of having
fake lightsaber fights in his driveway
so standing challenges in a bathtub
aren't really surprising at this point
ever since austin
and his shows popularized the format of
15 people in one stream competing for
something
the trend has taken off all over just
chatting
with clint's challenges being one
example of this
and i asked clint about the influence
that austin has had on his career
as well as the spike in viewership that
he sees whenever he does
these challenges in a lot of ways austin
is is indirectly responsible for
the majority of this sort of
sub-community you see just chatting he
and his original production team
pretty much brought that to the platform
in like a huge way and the majority of
the people that you see that
trickle down and watch people like me
are probably people that were introduced
to the concept
via austin he definitely just working
behind the scenes with him it was
cool to see how uh how like a big show
like that
was run but recently he made headlines
for a different
challenge getting pokeman's name and a
bunch of other random [ __ ]
tattooed on his lower back here's how it
went down
essentially clint created a spin to win
board with the options being
nothing absolutely nothing and get a
tattoo
now donating different amounts would do
different things donate
15 bucks and clint would spin a wheel
with a 1 in 15
chance of landing on tattoos which
didn't happen much
but if you donated 75 those odds slimmed
down to one
in three which went as well as you can
expect
oh wait no oh [ __ ] you put it over the
[ __ ] millionaire
no i put it on it i told you i was
putting it oh
[ __ ] what you know you have too much
time on your hands when you're sitting
in a bathtub
having random tattoos paid for by
literal strangers
actually now that i say that out loud
sounds kind of sick
my buddies convinced me that i was gonna
get loaded rich on gme
and i got in late and you know things
just didn't work out there so i thought
well i need to make some money quick so
that i can continue this lifestyle of
just doing nothing
and i thought the easiest way to
probably do this is to
basically come up with some sort of uh
concept that people are going to get
behind really quick financially that's
going to give them the most bang for
their buck
and i was on amazon just kind of
glancing around i saw i could buy a
tattoo gun for 22 dollars so i
pulled the trigger on it this wasn't
just one or two
either this dude's whole lower back was
covered in tattoos anyway the best part
about this whole
ordeal is when someone in the chat named
poop
got the bright idea that clint should
get pokeman's name
tattooed on his lower back and so
he did you have the camera in your hand
you [ __ ] idiot
simpin ain't easy i guess
now it might have been that clip or it
might have been when i told you that
this dude streams from his bathtub
but at some point you've probably asked
yourself
what the hell is going on and why do
people watch this dude
and all i can say is that this is just
twitch in 2021
the just chatting section acts as this
giant catch-all that includes
everything from code miko that human v
tuber hybrid i mentioned earlier
to dr k your favorite streamer's
therapist of choice
to cooking streams to half half-naked
streamers
to dudes sitting in their bathtubs
getting tattooed
it's become a place to experiment with
content but
it's also not unusual to see just
chatting streamers get
banned for pushing the boundaries of
what twitch is comfortable with
two examples of this that we've covered
recently are code miko who's been banned
three times by twitch since december of
2020
for showing a little too much digital
skin and accidentally leaking personal
info on stream
and then there's wes by the way who had
a long history of butting heads with
twitch
and was permabanned for putting food
into an inflatable pool
and swimming in it what is this thing
talking about giant dildos with youtuber
moist critical
or having pokeman yell simp over and
over
and over again
streamer west by the way has let's call
it a contentious relationship with
twitch
he's been handed multiple different
bands after tasteless jokes on different
streams
landed him predictably i must admit
in hot water with twitch now as for this
bathtub tattoo situation
it seems that clint did it again as a
challenge
which is the thinnest excuse to do
anything that i've ever heard
but speaking of pushing boundaries clint
has been banned before once after a
guest on his stream dropped the n-word
and with the tattoo stream you could
hear people on the call
warning him that he might get banned if
he showed blood or skin on stream
and so i asked clint if this was
something he was ever worried about
what happened was in december i was
trying to do a challenge with my boys to
see who could stand up while eating hot
dogs so long
and there was a party down the hall of
my apartment
and one of the neighbors would come in
and uh
he got into it with one of the kids that
were on my stream and he yeah he used uh
a word that he can't use no matter what
happens twitch definitely doesn't want
to lose a valuable
uh commodity like myself so i definitely
wasn't too too concerned about it but i
did do
the due diligence of at least turning
you know away from the camera
they couldn't see that now based on what
we've just gone through it might not be
surprising to hear that clint is no
stranger to controversy
back in september of 2020 he was accused
of rigging one of his challenge shows
that he hosted on a summary regular
basis
by one of austin's now former producers
specifically the survivor show which
worked like this
round by round contestants were voted
off similar to the survivor tv show
with the goal to be the last man
standing so you could win a couple
thousand dollars
now one of the twists here is that fans
could apparently buy
immunity tokens for their favorite
streamers bumping them into the next
round and keeping them safe
and according to the former producer
claw who tweeted out a lengthy
twitlonger
clint rigged the show by telling one of
the contestants named
auxis to buy immunity tokens for
contestants named barry in wet shrimp
under related names to make it look like
people were cheering for them
clint allegedly wanted wet shrimp and
berry to make the finals and win the
show because they were all friends
and allegedly wet trip said that if he
won he would give the money back to
clint
one of the contestants on that show even
tweeted out after the fact that she
thought the show was rigged
and that the benefits of being hosted
didn't really pan out for her
here is where things take an even
weirder turn
claw alleges that after he called out
clint for rigging this survivor show
[ __ ] basically swapped out all of the
emails in his
zoom account and took control of it
claus says that
clint then allegedly swapped the
licenses from
0 to 40 which charged claw
4 500 claw said that it was only once he
reached out to zoom through twitter that
he was able to find out what the emails
had been switched
to claw says once he found that out he
was able to take back control the zoom
account
and refund that 4 500 through paypal now
it's worth stating that everything i
just talked about here are allegations
and since those allegations were made
claw has faced his own controversy which
would take
far too much time to get through today
but what i will
say is that claw no longer works for
austin and
clint basically denies all of this there
wasn't a whole lot of freedoms to any of
it i think i think
last year we probably paid out something
over over 25 people people like will
neff
and and canoe and people like that were
were all coming forward and said hey no
i you know i got paid for the show and
um it's definitely real it's not rigged
or anything like that
that was really uh hard for me to deal
with but we got through it and
it sounds like he's doing better too and
i hope you know despite everything that
happened
i still wish the guy the best so there
you have it a story about a dude
his bathtub and his undying love for
pokeman who as far as i can tell
has yet to say anything about this
insanity
hey everyone it's your friendly
neighborhood editor colton here now you
might be wondering
what are you doing here well you might
have noticed in that video that devin's
mic sounded just a little bit
off now of course i could have just left
it at making it sound as good as
possible and
not bothered devin anymore but you all
know i'm not gonna [ __ ] do that
see devin's using a new microphone and
instead of speaking into the front of it
where his voice could be heard loud and
clear by all of you
he decided to speak into the back i
leave the rest to you
comment section